mr. America looking at the country is
not what I intended got a star to make a
change before the neverending story of
the failed nation once played out of
luck like a million Tyler Perry movies I
it suck all your little ham like to
still tell for sure warm or bone in
yourself interest now instead at the
core principles of made this country
broken true free to speak worship pursue
happiness too with all the money you
slide you're gonna be needing the big
free exercise the Fed tree at the
spending goes up you gotta borrow some
mo borrow went from the Chinese like oh
my lord you just a small you're
increasing the size of the federal
government yet a Georgia surprise you'll
be done like the Troy man no you ain't
coming back
forget it alone
logic
whichever side
America
don't you run away
Raisa problem Jimmy
Oh
my brave everyday making a monarchy of
my beloved us something you little
glitches need reminding of what we were
before and the siege that led us up to
Revolutionary War high taxes to the
throne without a voice of our own will
top down from the primer water left the
low are your folks off you're taking it
here up to here we will fight
redcoats why will ruin our beer now I'm
drinking spitting Cyprus to a grill made
of wood that's how it all went down and
g-dubs neighbourhood packing capital
balls like powder hammers Wilcox locks
click colossal - you don't know me
listen don't let it drizzle we kick the
eggs of the bees for much less than this
so don't deny the historical climbing
out of the mud follow me believe you
screenplay the seeds and be
watch it die
cha-ching
dr. Otto
freeze up and face up
I love to read
when it's really your 12 cami glasses
inception you can't be safe either fail
what happens when you keep printing mojo
both bodies of gold ring like that name
without go yeah but right now get ha hey
ain't you big hitter but now I'm back
from the dead I'll bring them back on my
[ __ ] what knickers no it's ok I can
say knickers because I wear knickers the
degradation of our freedoms and our
country head state government's getting
brave a private sector grows smaller for
now put your homies cuz here comes Dale
boxing
I just always feel the only change you
gonna be
gotcha
never
I promise
dr. Rana
so bad brain stuff
I love you
Oh
whoa
you